Hello guys and welcome back to yeagerists,
in today's video we will be going
through the story of Grisha Yeager.
Leave a like on this video and subscribe to our
channel if you want to see more content like this!
Grisha was born in Liberio in the year
806 on the continent of Marley. One day,
he and his sister ran out of the internment zone
chasing after an airship and were found out by two
Public Security Authorities officers. One of the
men punished Grisha while the other one took Faye
away. After the officer finished beating him, he
allowed Grisha to continue watching the airship,
stating since Grisha had already trespassed,
they might as well continue watching the airship.
However, when Grisha returned home. Faye was not
there. Her corpse was later found mangled in a
river. The Marleyan officers visited the family
home and explained that Faye and Grisha were at
fault for leaving and denied any knowledge of
her death. As Mrs. Yeager was filled with tears,
Mr. Yeager smiled and explained that he would
re-inform his son of their history. He then
explained the history of the Eldians and why their
ancestors' actions justify their outcast status
in Marleyan society. However, Grisha explained
that he believed the Marley men were lying and
tried to say they killed his sister but Mr.
Yeager silenced him and the two fought over their
situation as Eldians. Mr. Yeager tried to convince
his son why they needed to be punished but Grisha
expressed his belief that they should not have
to pay for the actions their ancestors committed.
Grisha continued to live his life being shamed for
being an Eldian and eventually became a doctor.
The meeting with Grice, a patient, led Grisha to
learn about the circumstances of Faye's death.
This gave him the motivation to
join the Eldian Restorationists.
Through his activities and a mole in
the Marley legal system named 'The Owl',
Grisha got information about Eldian history
and met Dina Fritz, a person of royal descent.
A year later they got married and
had a child which they named Zeke.
Later in their lives, Marleyan officials recruited
children to take on the power of the seven Titans
their people had stolen from the Eldians so many
years ago, so they could go to Paradis Island
and take down King Fritz, who had fled there
and built Walls for his people 80 years ago.
"The Owl" informed the group that Marley’s
real goal was to steal the Founding Titan,
so they could enhance their military might.
Grisha then decided he would send his own son
into the program as a mole for them.
Over time, Grisha and Dina began coming
increasingly distant with Zeke, leaving him at
Grisha's parents' house almost every night so
that they could attend meetings with the Eldian
Restorationists. Whenever he and Zeke had free
time, Grisha would spend it quizzing his son
on the "true" history of the Eldian race.
In the meantime, Grisha also learned from Grice
that Zeke would need to earn higher marks as a
Warrior Candidate if he was to be involved
in the plan to recapture the Founding Titan,
causing Grisha to put even more
stress on Zeke to become a Warrior.
However, after observing Zeke's poor performance
during a public training session, Grisha became
frustrated with his son, leading to a heated
argument with Dina about what to do with him.
One night during dinner, Zeke tried to convince
Grisha to stop helping the Eldian Restorationists.
Grisha was appalled at the idea, reminding Zeke
that the only way for Eldians to live in peace
was for the restorationists to overthrow Marley.
He was enraged to hear Zeke bring up Faye,
angrily telling him that the restorationists
were fighting with the express intent of making
sure that no one suffered the same fate as her.
However, he was taken aback by Zeke's accusation
that Faye's death was caused by his decision to
take her outside of the internment zone. Stunned
by Zeke's words, Grisha lamented that he had
only wanted to see an airship with his sister.
At the age of seven, Zeke exposed his
parents and all the restorationists,
and they were sentenced to go to
Paradis Island as Pure Titans.
After being turned in to the Public Security
Authorities, Grisha was subjected to nude
torture as the soldiers attempted to get him to
reveal who the Owl was by cutting off his fingers.
Once they gave up on obtaining the information,
Grisha and the rest of the restorationists were
taken to Paradis Island and sat on their
knees before a large Wall by the ocean.
After kicking Grice off the Wall alive, the rest
of the restorationists were turned into Titans
with Titan injection except for the Yeagers
and another member. When it was Dina's turn,
Grisha pleaded for her life, and tried to point
out that she was of royal descent and could be of
potential use to them, but was silenced by Kruger
before any of the soldiers could overhear him,
to Grisha's surprise. He watched her transform
into a Titan and run after their friend, Grice.
Sergeant Major Gross decided
not to turn Grisha into a Titan,
but to throw him to the other restorationist
after he had been transformed.
After adjusting the dose to create a 3-4m class
and injecting the other man with injection,
revealed to actually be Titan spinal fluid,
he threw him off the Wall to transform.
He began explaining how watching people
be devoured made him feel alive in such
a dull society. He then began pushing Grisha off
asking him to fight and die in an interesting way.
However, before he could do so, Kruger pushed
Gross off the Wall. As Gross is devoured,
Kruger asked Grisha if he enjoyed such a sight.
He then revealed that he was The Owl and claimed
that he would show Grisha how to truly use the
power of the Titans. Kruger then transformed
into a Titan and destroyed the steamboat
that took all the soldiers to the island.
After destroying the Marleyan men and
their equipment, Kruger returned to
the top of the Wall and, after introducing
himself and explaining how he became a spy,
he began to speak with Grisha who asked him
why he left only him alive. Kruger fell to
his knees from exhaustion and told Grisha of his
terrible acts against several thousand Eldians,
saying he did it all to serve Eldia in the end.
Kruger then said that he was entrusting Grisha
with his final mission, and went on to express
regret for playing a role in his sister’s death,
but that the hatred he saw in Grisha's eyes the
next day was part of the reason he chose him.
This reminded Kruger of his own uprising, when
he watched his family be burned alive and chose
to get revenge for them, however, it turned
out that he had to torture fellow Eldians to
maintain his identity until that day. Kruger
told Grisha that he must enter the Walls and
take back the Founding Titan, using the power
of the Titans Kruger would give him. Grisha then
asked why Kruger was not doing it himself, but
Kruger explained that 13 years after inheriting
the power of one of the Nine Titans, the host
would die, and it had been 13 years for him.
He then explained that all Eldians are connected
by paths to the Founding Titan Ymir Fritz once had
and that no one can ever be stronger than
her, so they die after 13 years as she did.
Grisha then questioned this logic and the Eldian
history, which Kruger explained is probably not
true from the Marleyan or Eldian perspective.
When Grisha asked Kruger why he let the Marleyans
turn Dina, he said that since Dina had royal
blood, it was too risky for her to remain;
she had to go before Zeke could tell Marley more.
When Grisha objected, he asked Grisha if Dina
being forced to bear Marley's children for the
rest of her miserable life would have been better.
Grisha told him that he did not believe he was
fit to take on his mission, and that he would not
have paid the price for freedom if he knew what
it was. Kruger then commended Grisha's father
for trying to keep his family safe when he knew
what happened to Faye. Kruger confronted Grisha,
and told him that the reason he chose him is that
at the expense of others, he sought freedom by
going past the Walls. He said that their brothers
and sisters paid the price for their freedom,
and that those actions will follow them until they
are repaid, even after death. Grisha then stood
up and accepted Kruger’s mission. He then told
him the name of the Titan he was going to take:
the Attack Titan. After taking his power,
Grisha went to the Walls and began his mission.
Grisha was found wandering outside the Walls
near the Shiganshina District by Keith Shadis,
a soldier of the Survey Corps. The
soldier was very surprised to see him,
not only because he was outside the Walls, but
also because he claimed to have suffered amnesia
and he had no memories about the
civilization inside the Walls and the
military. Amazed to learn that the Eldians of
the Walls were attempting to fight the Titans,
Grisha claimed to have amnesia.
Keith brought Grisha back to
Shiganshina, where he was imprisoned
for illegally entering Titan territory.
While imprisoned, he claimed to remember his
name. Upon release, Grisha revealed to Keith
that he "remembered" being a doctor, and asked him
for knowledge about the world inside the Walls.
Keith took Grisha to a pub in Shiganshina
where Keith taught him about the world.
Suitably impressed by the life that the Eldians
of the Walls had managed to build for themselves,
Grisha was surprised to hear that Keith was
unhappy with the state of the Walls, and had
joined the Survey Corps in the hope of seeing the
larger world. Praising Keith and the Survey Corps,
Grisha caught the attention of a nearby barmaid
named Carla, who began to chastise Keith for
attempting to recruit more people to the Corps.
However, Grisha assured her that even if he was
offered the chance, he would not join them as the
Corps required special people to join its ranks.
Grisha eventually found work at a hospital.
When an epidemic broke out in Shiganshina,
Grisha was able to successfully cure those
afflicted including Carla and her parents.
Grisha and Carla eventually married each
other. At a party after the wedding ceremony,
Grisha began to tell guests about
how Keith introduced him to Carla,
before realizing that Keith had left the party
early. He and Carla would later have a son, Eren.
Grisha used his occupation as a doctor to get
close with government officials in order to
gather information on the ruler of
the Walls and continue his mission
as a Restorationist. He eventually discovered
the location of the Reiss family's chapel,
as well as the hatch leading down to the
basement where the succession rituals take place.
However, he chose to delay his mission
in favor of staying with his new family.
Years later, Grisha was making a
house call, with Eren tagging along,
to Mr. Ackerman and Mikasa's mother
for an appointed medical examination
in the year 844. When he arrived there,
he found them dead for hours. He asked
Eren if he had seen the girl named Mikasa
anywhere, but he was too shocked to answer.
He then told Eren to wait for him at the foot of
the mountain while he finds the Military Police.
After the MPs and Grisha arrived at the murderers'
hideout, Grisha hugged Eren and scolded him for
the murders he committed when saving Mikasa,
asking if he even understood what he had done.
However, instead of continuing to scold him
for killing Mikasa's kidnappers, he tells him
that this time he was lucky and he could have been
killed himself. Mikasa, cold and depressed, asked
Grisha in what direction her home was and stated
that she was cold and wants to leave. In response,
Eren gave her his scarf and Grisha
told her to come live with them.
Despite not going through immediately with
his mission, Grisha felt that his family,
especially Eren, deserved to know the truth about
life outside the Walls. At night, Grisha would go
into the Yeager family basement and write down
information about his former life in Marley.
After compiling everything into three journals,
Grisha inscribed a message revealing that humanity
was still alive beyond the walls on the back of
his old family's photograph and hid all of his
writings in his desk. He then locked the basement
door, keeping the key on him at all times.
Upon learning from Mikasa that Eren
wants to join the Survey Corps,
Grisha is more obliging of the idea than Carla
and asks his son why he wants to leave the Walls.
Eren's answer, that the deaths of the many
soldiers who have already served in the Survey
Corps will be a waste if no one continues the
fight, galvanizes Grisha to resume his mission to
retake the Founding Titan from the Reiss family.
Grisha announces that he will be departing,
telling a bewildered Carla that there is no point
in trying to stop an inquisitive mind like Eren's.
Before he leaves, he promises to show Eren what he
has been hiding in their basement when he returns.
Grisha reflects on what he must do
the entire way to the Reiss chapel,
seeing through the future memories of the Attack
Titan that the day had come when Wall Maria would
fall. Bursting in on the royal family, Grisha
reveals himself to be an Eldian from beyond the
Walls and begs Frieda Reiss to use her Founding
Titan ability to save Shiganshina from the Titans
that are breaking in. However, succumbing to
the will of Karl Fritz, she refuses to act.
Grisha argues that the Eldians within the
Walls should not be killed for crimes their
ancestors committed which they are not even
aware of, but his protests fall on deaf ears.
Frieda attempts to explain to him that there is
no point in stealing the Founding Titan's power
as only the royal family can use it, but Grisha
reveals that he is already aware of this fact;
the Attack Titan's inheritors have the ability to
see the memories of the Titan's future inheritors,
giving them the ability to see the future.
Grisha proclaims that since the royal family
is bound by Karl Fritz's vow, he will steal the
Founding Titan away from them. However, despite
his threats, Grisha is unable to bring himself
to kill the entire Reiss family, horrified at the
thought of killing children. It is only when Eren,
acting through the timeless paths in the future
year 854, demands he fulfill his duty by reminding
him of his fellow restorationists and his dead
sister Faye that Grisha finally transforms.
Grisha easily beats Frieda in combat and devours
her before going on to slaughter the entire Reiss
family, sparing only Rod Reiss on Eren's orders.
Exiting the chapel, Grisha is left horrified
by his actions. On the verge of hysteria,
Grisha demands Eren to tell him if this is what
he wanted. He begins asking aloud why Eren did
not show him everything that will come to pass
and, due to them living next to the Wall, hopes
that Carla is safe and was able to get away; he
asks himself again if this was the only way before
realizing that Zeke's future self is also visiting
him through the paths. Grisha tells his eldest son
that only Eren's plan will succeed, but laments
that Eren's plan will lead to "ghastly" events.
Looking up, he realizes that he can actually
see the future Zeke and embraces him,
apologizing for being a horrible father and
begging for him to find a way to stop Eren's plan.
Traveling to Trost District, Grisha locates Keith
Shadis and enlists his help in searching for his
family among the refugees. Upon finding Eren, the
two men learn that Carla has been devoured by a
Titan. Grisha is devastated and, thinking back
to his interaction with Eren at the Reiss chapel,
realizes why he did not reveal what happened.
Accepting that his successor is indeed Eren,
Grisha merely tells him that he must avenge
his mother and takes Eren into the woods.
When Keith tries to stop him, arguing that
Grisha should not put such a burden on the
boy's shoulders as he might not be gifted like
Grisha, Grisha simply explains that the fact
that Eren is his son makes him qualified
and orders Keith not to get involved.
In the forest, he entrusts Eren with the key to
his basement and injects him with a Titan serum,
explaining to Eren that their memories will
teach him how to use the ability. Grisha is
immediately devoured by Eren, transferring both
the Founding Titan and Attack Titan to him.
Thank you guys so much for watching
this video, it really means a lot to us.
We will see you guys very soon
in one of our next videos!